le livre que j'ai écrit c'est une pièce
de théâtre
d'accord je veux le souligner parce que
on oublie trop souvent que le théâtre a
deux aspects c'est à dire l'aspect
littéraire et l'aspect on va dire mise
en scène de représentation avec donc une
mise en scène des comédiens décors etc
je crois que l'on oublie trop souvent
que le théâtre son essence c'est cela
aussi est donc moi je me suis en quelque
sorte occupé de toute la partie
littéraire c'est à dire c'est une pièce
de théâtre jeudi de quoi il s'agit je
mets en place un dispositif de nature
gic qui fait que lorsqu'on le lit on se
projette effectivement dans le cadre
d'une pièce de théâtre véritablement
mais on n'en est pas encore à la pièce à
ce moment là et donc le travail du
metteur en scène et de prendre en charge
en quelque sorte 7,7
le livre ce qui est écrit
pour cette fois ci le transposer sur
scène et c'est une autre dimension du
travail et c'est donc cela que l'on va
voir dans le cadre donc de ces deux
représentations communes y sont proposés
le 19
juillet et le 20 juillet prochain
qu'attendez vous réellement de cette
publication de cette opération
alors d'abord ce que j'attends de la
publication c'est que les lecteurs
puissent découvrir cette histoire qu'il
s'en approprient et qu'ils comprennent
surtout qu'elle a été véritablement là
la profondeur je dirais de ce qui a
conduit à l'arrestation de ces hommes et
ce qui constituait en quelque sorte les
véritables raisons pour lesquelles ils
ont été arrêtés ça le livre leu leu leu
leu raconte parfaitement bien c'est tout
à fait bien exposé pour ce qui concerne
la pièce de théâtre comme c'en est une
adaptation c'est la traduction de ce qui
a été écrit mais que l'on retrouve sur
scène donc là on prend en quelque sorte
il ya un autre rapport c'est sans
rapport avec la scène c'est ce rapport
privilégié que l'on a d'entendre la
parole d'entendre les mots de voir les
mots en quelque sorte être porté à notre
à notre attention et comment ces mots là
vont en quelque sorte raisonnée et là
c'est que le théâtre qui peut nous le
donner évidemment nous sommes bien loin
du procès véritable mais le procès
véritable ce n'était pas non plus une
pièce de théâtre donc le lien entre le
procès véritable est ce que moi j'ai
fait comme travail c'est que le théâtre
nous aident en quelque sorte à venir
rencontrer cette parole et c'est cela
qui a c'est en cela qu'il y a un intérêt
majeur c'est cette rencontre avec la
parole cette rencontre avec les hommes
qui ont eu à vivre ces moments là mais
cette fois ci on va dire d'un point de
vue plus
plus qui tient plus de la mise en scène
voilà